turning to our reporting on resilience
this morning we meet a couple determined
to realize our lifelong dream of owning
their own business when their new york
restaurant was hit hard by the pandemic
the couple refused to close their doors
and kept going with the power of their
own determination our senior medical
correspondent dr tara narula is here
with their story of resilience along
with some key strategies to help us all
get through challenging times tara good
morning good morning vlad gloribel perez
and walid marabit were small business
owners when the pandemic threatened to
close the doors of their restaurant what
kept them going was a resilience they
say they never knew they had but experts
say it was there all along
we're going to make it happen
you know it for gloribel perez and her
husband waleed murabit owning a business
was their american dream
in october of 2019 their restaurant
barcha was born
[Applause]
this restaurant was your dream yeah as
someone who
chose this country who immigrated here
and to be able to make something and
build something with my life partner
it's
it just meant everything and the couple
was overjoyed when only four months
after their grand opening their latin
fused labor of love was quickly becoming
a favorite in their east harlem
neighborhood
and then covet hit your whole world
turns upside down yeah absolutely it was
a bit of a spiral of despair for a bit
there
although i didn't have all the
information i needed at the time and i
still don't i knew how to figure it out
to stay afloat the couple made some big
adjustments including shifting to an
online business and partnering with
rethink a company that provides support
to restaurants in food and secure
communities what do you think it was in
your backgrounds that gave you that
attitude of we have to figure out life
we have to pivot and problem solve i
think the totality of my lived
experience has made me resilient and i
think this pandemic has through no
choice of our own has made us all
resilient as well adversity
doesn't
discriminate most experts would agree
that we are all actually hardwired to
overcome life's biggest challenges
do you think that we as a society
recognize how resilient we are i think
sadly a lot of people think of it as
some kind of elusive trait that some
people have and other people don't
the normal response is actually
resilience lucy hohn is the co-director
at the new zealand institute of
well-being and resilience her ted talk
one of the most viewed of 2020
highlights the three secrets of
resilient people so number one for
starters learning to accept that
struggle and challenge are a part of
everyday life they are universal so that
when something goes wrong
this stops you from feeling
discriminated against it stops you from
feeling singled out honest book
resilient grieving was born out of her
own personal tragedy when in 2014 her 12
year old daughter abby was killed in a
car accident i literally went from being
this supposed resilient expert to
my whole life smashed to smithereens
really amidst her grief hon zeroed in on
specific ways of thinking she says are
critical to helping us navigate the most
difficult times in our lives resilient
people are really good at focusing their
attention on the things
that they can change
and somehow accepting
the things that they can't change and
her third and final strategy one she
calls self-regulation focus on positive
thinking and living the people who
manage to cope
with really terrible things
very often have a real sense
of personal
mission and when life gets in the way
says hohn find a way to chart a new
course for gloribel perez and walid
marabit having adapted to a new business
model providing meals for their food
insecure neighbors their mission now is
giving back to the community they love
one meal at a time i go at home and go
to sleep at night i'm not stressed
because i've done something good that
day giving back has helped you survive
in more ways than one absolutely i am
walking in the steps
of the person that i want to be
running a purpose-driven business you
can still keep moving forward to reach
your goals this is a process that we're
going through and in knowing that that
allows us to have the resilience to just
keep going
lucy hones says in her book hope is the
fuel that fires us to move forward in
the world and tells us people need to
believe in hope that we have an
incredible capacity to cope even in our
darkest days and she highlights the idea
that part of resilience is being able to
shift your goal posts and realize you
can have many hopes saying the thing to
do is to ask yourself even though it
feels like all hope is lost what else
are you hoping for now and you know she
she told us that when she lost her
daughter her hopes became i hope my boys
live happy healthy lives i hope my
husband and i can be there for each
other i hope i can continue to do
meaningful work that behavioral mental
flexibility is so key she says yeah i
learned that you know that book man's
search for meaning by viktor frankl it's
one of my favorite books of all time he
talks about what it took for holocaust
survivors to get through something like
that it's exactly what you just said in
your tag moving the goal post and
believing that there will be a hopeful
day down the line the serenity to accept
the things you cannot change the courage
to change the things you can and the
wisdom to know the difference yeah the
words my mom told me from a very young
age stays with me always me too tara
thank you very much wow